[ __ ] way there's no way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey okay why didn't check again cuz I
called 30 minutes going someone said
that as I said there are four names on
this list
no excuse me sorry we walk around and do
some whips around we're not gonna we're
not gonna walk anywhere sorry about the
whole restaurant I'll see you again soon
okay great all right bye
just wanted to call see if you got my
text from the other week
hit me up send me a message on facebook
or something I'm around I had my phone
on me pretty nice right
yeah man I think she's like [ __ ]
punch me taste it
give him my phone give me my [ __ ]
phone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Fred
well let you know Fred I'll let you know
but I'll let you know
actually can you start on Monday here
it's kind of tricky you have to just
check this out [ __ ] nice right stop
hey what's up who's that for
oh um sorry thank you
excuse me so Fred there's a few things
that I really need to talk through with
you I've been hearing about
inappropriate behavior
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]